bonjour à tous La séance est ouverte sur
LCP à l'ordre du jour un projet de loi
pour accélérer le développement des
énergies renouvelables en France dans ce
domaine notre pays est en retard le
renouvelable c'est à peine 15% de la
production d'électricité contre 46% au
Danemark le gouvernement veut donc
simplifier les procédures
administratives pour permettre le
déploiement massif de parc éolien en mer
sur terre et l'installation de panneaux
solaires dans les parkings ou encore les
bordures d'autoroute la parole est à
Agnès panier renacher la ministre de la
transition écologique qui défend à la
tribune un texte historique les Français
ne comprendraient pas que nous renvoyons
à demain l'accélération de production
d'énergie dans notre pays en retard de
20% sur les objectifs que nous nous
étions fixés dans la précédente
programmation plus réelle de l'énergie
en retard également sur nos voisins
puisque la France est le seul pays de
l'Union européenne à ne pas avoir
atteint ses objectifs en matière
d'énergie renouvelable il nous faut donc
rattraper ce retard et pour cela ne pas
se tromper de combat je tiens à rappeler
une évidence que nous n'avons peut-être
pas assez entendu ces derniers jours le
seul combat qu'il convient de mener
c'est celui des énergies décarbonées
contre les énergies fossiles dans ce
combat nous ne pouvons toujours perdre
notre temps opposer les technologies
entre elles mais à la fin ce seront
toujours les Français qui paieront le
prix de ces postures dogmatiques toutes
les énergies ont des avantages et des
gens qui inconvénients toutes à nous
responsables politiques de construire la
meilleure combinaison de ces énergies
pour bâtir le futur de notre système
énergétique à nous aussi de dépasser les
clivage en nous inscrivant dans les pas
de l'appel de Johannesburg lancé par
Jacques Chirac du Grenelle de
l'environnement conduit par Nicolas
Sarkozy et Jean-Louis Borloo ou de
l'accord de Paris sur le climat porté
par François Hollande et Laurent Fabius
le texte que je vous présente
aujourd'hui s'inscrit dans cet esprit il
est les fruits des échanges que j'ai eu
depuis plusieurs mois maintenant avec
des acteurs associatifs et économiques
avec les élus locaux et leur association
il est le fruit aussi du travail entamé
très en amont avec les parlementaires au
Sénat comme à l'Assemblée nationale à
cet égard je tiens à souligner la
qualité des échanges et du travail
conduit par les quatre rapports eau de
Luquet pierre Cazeneuve Henri alfanderi
et Eric Bothorel et par les présidents
des commissions du développement durable
et de l'aménagement du territoire et des
affaires économiques Jean-Marc zulisy et
Guillaume kasbarian
comme vous le savez ce projet de loi
porte 4 objectifs premier objectif
changer de paradigme et construire une
véritable méthode de planification des
énergies renouvelables au niveau
territorial et conduite par les élus de
terrain deuxième objectif accélérer les
procédures administratives sans rien
renier à nos exigences environnementales
troisième objectif faire preuve de bon
sens et déployer les énergies
renouvelables particulièrement
photovoltaïques en libérant du foncier
artificialisé ou dégradé quatrième et
dernier objectif
améliorer la désirabilité et
l'appropriation des énergies
renouvelables notamment par un meilleur
partage de la valeur des projets le
texte voté en commission montre que les
chemins pour bâtir des compromis
existent je m'attacherai à ce que nos
échanges se poursuivent dans ce même
esprit de co-construction je voudrais à
ce titre prendre le temps de présenter
certains enjeux spécifiques du texte sur
lesquels vous êtes je le sais
particulièrement attentif la
planification d'abord l'objet de cette
planification est de remettre les
territoires et les élus locaux au centre
des décisions pour cela nous donnons le
pouvoir de décider aux élus locaux des
leviers pour aménager leur territoire en
décidant des zones d'accélération où il
souhaite accueillir des projets
d'énergie renouvelables et les zones où
ils souhaitent au contraire les limiter
ce sont donc les communes qui proposent
et se sont elles qui ont le dernier mot
aucune commune ne pourra se faire
imposer une zone d'accélération sur son
territoire nous souhaitons bâtir un
nouveau pacte territorial où l'État joue
un rôle de facilitateur nous mettrons
notamment à disposition les données les
cartographies et les référents
préfectoraux que nous nommerons seront
chargés d'accompagner les collectivités
locales
les débats de qualité en commission ont
toutefois montré que nous devons encore
lever certains points sur ce sujet de la
planification combien de temps
laissons-nous pour définir ces zones
quel sort pour les communes sans
document d'urbanisme nous y avons
beaucoup travaillé ces derniers jours
avec vous et les associations des locaux
le gouvernement portera avec leur
rapporteur Alfandari des amendements
pour répondre à ces différentes
questions et préciser le dispositif
deuxième sujet la grivevoltaïsme sur ce
sujet notre objectif est de concilier
souveraineté alimentaire et souveraineté
énergétique face à l'anarchie actuelle
il nous faut légiférer c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous soutenons la
proposition de loi du Sénat qui a été
intégrée à ce projet de loi pour la
première fois nous donnons endroit une
définition de la grivevoltaïsme avec des
conditions et un encadrement équilibré
et clair
pour s'assurer de la réussite du
dispositif le Gouvernement soutiendra
l'amendement du rapporteur bottorell qui
portait par la même philosophie que le
système de planification dont je parlais
propose de faire confiance au local pour
prendre en compte les spécificités
agricoles de nos territoires
concrètement dans chaque département un
documentaire co-construit par l'ensemble
des partis prenantes locales et
entérinés par le préfet permettra de
préciser les caractéristiques de la
compatibilité des installations
photovoltaïques avec l'activité agricole
troisième sujet le partage de la valeur
c'est un apport majeur de ce texte pour
assurer que les habitants et les
communes et directement accès aux
retombées de ces projets et soit associé
à leur réussite la création d'un fonds
de financement d'action locale pour les
collectivités d'un second fond dédié à
la biodiversité et l'ouverture d'un
financement participatif des habitants
au projet sur leur territoire sont des
apports politiques
que nous soutenons par ailleurs si je
reste convaincu que les Françaises et
les Français doivent aussi bénéficier du
partage de la valeur j'ai entendu vos
inquiétudes
concernant le dispositif initial de
réduction directe sur les factures des
riverains c'est pourquoi le gouvernement
portera plusieurs amendements permettant
collectivités de soutenir leur habitants
et soutiendra les amendements portés par
le groupe socialiste qui cible les
ménages en précarité énergétique
quatrième sujet l'accélération des
renouvelables en zone déjà
artificialisée en matière d'énergie
renouvelable les bâtiments constituent
une priorité et des mesures importantes
avaient déjà été prise avec la loi
climat et résilience pour aller encore
plus loin le Gouvernement soutiendra le
dispositif ambitieux mais équilibré de
l'amendement 2823 portée par le groupe
Renaissance
il propose des objectifs croissants mais
progressifs pour les nouveaux bâtiments
cela permettra de maintenir l'ambition
de la mesure votée en commission tout en
permettant une flexibilité nécessaire
cinquième sujet la raison impérative
d'intérêt public majeur sur ce sujet le
gouvernement défendra un amendement de
rétablissement de la rédaction initiale
je sais que cela soulève des
incompréhensions voire des craintes
certains pour des raisons de protection
de la biodiversité d'autres car ils ne
sont justement pas vraiment convaincus
de l'impérius nécessité pour notre
avenir énergétique de développer les
énergies renouvelables si je pense avoir
longuement répondu au second au début de
ce discours quelques mots pour les
premiers cette mesure vise à mettre fin
à une pratique quasi systématique de
recours dilatoire contre les projets
sur le fond cette mesure qui vient
d'être adoptée au niveau européen avec
le soutien large des groupes représentés
au Parlement européen dont les Verts ne
revient pas sur les conditions à remplir
en matière d'impact environnemental qui
reste cumulatif et obligatoire pour une
demande de dérogation à l'obligation de
protection stricte des espèces protégées
il est donc clair que ce gouvernement ne
sacrifiera pas la biodiversité au profit
du climat enfin je me réjouis que ce
texte facilite le développement des
énergies renouvelables dans les
territoires d'outre-mer c'est absolument
stratégique pour l'autonomie énergétique
de ces territoires alors que beaucoup
connaissent des difficultés sur ces
questions je tiens à remercier les
députés des outre-mer et des zones non
interconnectées pour le travail
collectif mené sur ces sujets
mesdames et messieurs les députés je
sais qu'ensemble durant les heures qui
sont devant nous nous saurons encore
améliorer le texte et je suis confiante
sur le fait que de gauche à droite dans
cette émission parmi les nombreuses
bonnes volontés qui siègent nous serons
aussi nous accorder sur l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est faire face à la crise
énergétique pour le pouvoir d'achat des
Français et la compétitivité des
entreprises ces défendre l'indépendance
industrielle énergétique et politique de
notre pays
c'est lutter contre le dérèglement
climatique pour l'avenir de nos enfants
car c'est bien tout l'enjeu de ce texte
je vous remercie
merci Madame la Ministre ce projet loi
sur les énergies renouvelables c'est le
grand texte législatif de cette fin
d'année pas moins de 4 rapports sont
mobilisés sur le chantier il défendent à
la tribune point par point les lignes de
force de ce texte censé garantir
l'indépendance de la France face à la
crise énergétique et aux dérèglement
climatique
les sénateurs nous ont apporté une
excellente base de travail sur laquelle
nous avons pu nous appuyer en commission
et nous les remercions pour ce travail
la guerre en Ukraine nous le rappelle
l'enjeu primordial est de retrouver
notre souveraineté énergétique et de
moins dépendre des autres pays nul
besoin d'étendre nos discussions sur la
relance de la production nucléaire nous
aurons l'occasion d'échanger longuement
sur ce sujet au début de l'année
prochaine cependant il est évident que
construire de nouveaux réacteurs prendra
de nombreuses années nous ne pouvons
attendre de tels échéances pour
entreprendre la décarbonation de notre
société neutralité carbone en 2050 c'est
dès maintenant qu'il faut réussir un
profond revirement de nos productions et
de nos usages
notre retard actuel dans l'attein des
objectifs de notre politique énergétique
exige détermination et ambitions pour
nous permettre de dépasser les résultats
déjà accomplis le consensus a fait
lentement son chemin dans notre pays les
Français reconnaissent aujourd'hui que
pour faire face aux enjeux du climat et
à la décarbonation des activités la
rapide mobilisation et le déploiement
des énergies renouvelables est
nécessaire aux côtés du renforcement de
nos capacités en énergie nucléaire
et de l'énergie fossile importée
cela constitue à la fois une
extraordinaire
dépendance vis-à-vis de certains pays
mais aussi un impact particulièrement
conséquent sur nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre
ce projet de loi il répond donc à un
double objectif le premier c'est
renforcer notre souveraineté énergétique
le second c'est lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique pour se faire
nous devons actionner deux leviers le
premier c'est la sobriété et
l'efficience
en réduisant de 40% notre consommation
énergétique d'ici 2050 le second
c'est la production massive d'énergie
décarbonée à savoir le nucléaire et les
énergies renouvelables
c'est de cela dont on parle ce texte
d'intensifier massivement et
immédiatement notre production d'énergie
renouvelable si je suis un grand
défenseur de l'atome je suis aussi
persuadé que la bonne réponse réside
dans une lecture scientifique et
rationnelle de la situation
nous sommes en 1901 Émile Zola publie
son dernier roman travail une œuvre
d'anticipation qui nous plonge dans la
création d'une cité utopique qui devra
faire face au temps où le charbon
s'épuiserait au fond des mines se pose
alors la question de l'alternative pour
assurer dit-il le torrent d'électricité
devenu indispensable à l'existence
c'est alors que sous les traits d'un
inventeur il se lance dans cette quête
qu'il amènera à se tourner vers le ciel
pour s'adresser directement au soleil se
courable Zola écrit de la sorte il y
aura sans cesse là une source de force
illimitée dont on disposerait à sa guise
le soleil apparaît alors pour l'écrivain
comme la seule énergie susceptible
d'émanciper l'humanité encore faut-il la
maîtriser il ajoute des savants étaient
parvenus à imaginer de petits appareils
qui captaient la chaleur solaire et la
transformait en électricité mais par
quantité infime il fallait réaliser le
phénomène en grand
réaliser ce phénomène en grand voilà
bien notre ambition aujourd'hui dans
avec ce projet de loi cette ressource
nous voulons la mettre au coeur de la
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
et incontestablement le défi de notre
siècle notre volonté est claire faire de
la France le premier grand pays du monde
à sortir de la dépendance aux énergies
fossiles
c'est un impératif pour protéger notre
environnement renforcer notre
souveraineté et améliorer le pouvoir
d'achat des Français le texte examiné a
été largement adopté par les sénateurs
La droite majoritaire au Palais du
Luxembourg a voté pour mais à
l'Assemblée nationale le projet de loi
ne fait pas tout à fait l'unanimité lors
de la discussion générale qui ouvre les
débats certains députés font entendre
leurs réserves sur le projet de loi
madame la mini chère collègue
normalement nous aurions dû avoir une
motion de procédure
les services ont fait une erreur et au
regard de leur charge de travail
d'ailleurs je ne leur en veux pas c'est
la raison pour laquelle je n'ai pas fait
modifier le déroulé de notre séance et
que je vais me concentrer sur
l'intervention générale
allons nous passer l'hiver
pas de panique nous rassure-t-on au
Palais de l'Élysée il y aura pas de
coupure si le temps est bon s'il n'y a
pas trop de vent s'il ne pleut pas s'il
fait beau peut-être bref si nous avons
de la chance
tous responsables et pas de panique
voilà un slogan qui aurait pu lancer le
capitaine du Titanic
en plein milieu du naufrage
SCARL l'iceberg est devant nous la coque
du navire s'en approche à pleine vitesse
et à défaut d'une véritable stratégie
pour son détourner évitez ainsi des
mesures de détestage humiliantes et aux
conséquences difficiles pour les ménages
pour les entreprises le gouvernement
nous a dégoté un nouvel outil aussi
gadget que dérisoire et coat
le nouveau Bison Futé des délaissage qui
nous permet de savoir dans quel état se
trouve le réseau électrique comment ils
risquent d'être coupé surtout à quelle
heure un outil pour gérer la peur et la
panique plutôt que pour gérer la crise
puisque nous ne savons pas quels sont
les mesures concrètes qui vont nous
permettre de passer l'hiver
doit-on encore une fois comme lors de la
crise du covid constaté l'impuissance de
l'État et son remettre à nous-mêmes
est-ce devenu ça l'Etat un gestionnaire
d'applications de crise et de pénurie ce
matin le président de RTE a parlé de
mesure de délestage aux conditionnelles
une preuve que la stratégie de
communication probablement orchestrée
par mckinzee ou autre et bien vidé les
seconds couteaux font le tour des
plateaux de télévision et de radio pour
préparer une éventuelle crise et deux
scénarios ensuite se dessine soit il y a
des stages et vous pourrez dire nous
l'avions prévu tout va bien se passer
soit il n'y a pas de délestage et vous
pourrez dire nous l'avions prévu tout
s'est bien passé
en vérité nous sommes aujourd'hui nous
aveugles et démunis les multiplications
des menaces sur notre sécurité
d'approvisionnement la vague de froid
qui s'abat sur d'autres pays conjugué au
dysfonctionnements chroniques du marché
de l'énergie empêche le Parlement et les
Français de savoir qui est responsable
comment cette situation a pu se produire
aussi allons-nous examiner le projet de
loi d'accélération des ENR un beau
prétexte pour ignorer la situation en
cours et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous vous demandons d'écouter la
proposition formulée par le président
Chassaigne d'organiser un débat au
Parlement de toute urgence sur cette
question de délestage il est nécessaire
que la transparence soit faite au moment
même où nous traversons cette crise nous
avons besoin de savoir pourquoi depuis
six ans de président de la République
est en responsabilité lui et sa majorité
n'ont rien fait pour stabiliser la
production d'électricité du pays
pourquoi ce projet de loi est celui de
l'accélération du nucléaire
interviennent maintenant alors que déjà
à l'époque Emmanuel Macron connaissait
l'état de vieillissement de nos
centrales alors aujourd'hui plutôt que
de débattre sur un projet de loi qui
nous résoudra pas la crise de Libert qui
vient nous exigeons un nouveau débat sur
la question des dédestas et demandons à
ce que les élus locaux les acteurs des
collectivités du quotidien soient
associées des députés communistes du
groupe Geder vous alerte depuis des
années sur le risque que fait peser le
marché de l'énergie sur notre
indépendance énergétique ces alertes
sont devenus concrètes à présent nous
aurions besoin en urgence de revoir
l'organisation de ce marché et ne pas
inverser le calendrier législatif pour
discuter le plus rapidement de notre PPE
afin d'adapter notre offre aux besoins
car cette crise n'est pas celle d'un
moment d'une conjoncture elle est bien
plus profonde plus structurelle la
situation que nous connaissons depuis
des mois n'est pas le fruit du hasard ou
seulement de la guerre en Ukraine
démarrer en février les prix de
l'énergie ont explosé bien avant
l'invasion russe le gouv était
d'ailleurs obligé d'intervenir dès
octobre 2021 pour faire face à
l'augmentation
majeure des prix 50% depuis la
libéralisation complète pour le gaz et
de l'électricité en 2007 et cette
frénésie à la hausse ne semble pas
vouloir s'arrêter vous contraignant à
dégainer le bouclier tarifaire en forme
de passoire sur le dos d'EDF pourquoi
parce que vous avez confié le soin au
marché de régler le problème de gestion
d'un bien commun comme l'énergie
initié par la gauche qui avait renoncé
et par une droite libérale la
dérégulation a été ce grand mouvement de
destruction du service public national
que constituer EDF et GDF un modèle
envié par tous qui a permis tous les
grands investissements et les grands
projets par le passé
mais le vent mauvais le vent du marché
est passé par là et à présent la
dérégulation nous expose désormais à
toutes les spéculations indexations du
prix d'électricité sur le prix du gaz la
question n'est pas encore réglée à
l'échelle européenne libéralisation des
prix fin programmer des tarifs
réglementés de vente pour les clients
résidentiels qui est d'ores et déjà acté
et impactés pour les collectivités
locales et des millions d'entreprises de
ce point de vue je veux insister sur
l'absence d'efficacité du filet de
sécurité que vous avez mis en place pour
les collectivités l'usine à gaz que
continue de représenter les mécanismes
d'aide de nos entreprises dont la
compétitivité est sérieusement mis en
danger dans ces temps ce système que
beaucoup ici ont contribué à ériger
depuis 25 ans à méticuleusement détruit
les fondements sur lesquels reposent
l'équilibre européen multiplication des
mécanismes de marché de soutien à la
concurrence sont développés de politique
structurantes au plan industriel un dé
message qui a si bien fonctionné que
sont arrivés sur le marché de l'énergie
des marchands de savonnettes comme on
dit chez moi les total énergie et
compagnies qui au détriment des
opérateurs publics n'ont pas développé
de nouvelles capacités de production
mais qui ont profité des fruits des
investissements publics des autres
notamment par le mécanisme de la reine
pour faire du low cost du démarchage
abusif de la concurrence bas de gamme là
où il n'y avait pas de besoin un beau
résultat puisque 12 ans après la loi
Nome nous avons perdu des moyens de
production pilotables la fermeture de
Fessenheim en 2018 et l'illustration de
cela un beau résultat puisque EDF a été
siphonné par la concurrence et malmené
par des steps n'go dans tous les
domaines salarial rechercher
développement et j'en passe à tel point
qu'aujourd'hui en France pour faire face
au grand carénage pour faire face aux
corrosion sous contrainte pour faire
face aux enjeux de PR à penlis chez moi
notamment nous manquons renouvellement
de soudeur ainsi empêtré dans la mise à
mort de son service public et de soutien
la concurrence libre et non faussée
notre pays c'est aussi embourbé dans un
retard considérable pour décarboner
notre mix énergétique la France est
encore très largement dépendante des
hydrocarbures et n'a pas réussi à
enclencher une montée en puissance de
l'électrification de la consommation
énergétique afin de faire baisser la
demande de par primaire des énergies
fossiles notre pays avait pourtant
encore des atouts pour réaliser ce défi
et cette transition des salariés de très
haut niveau un réseau électrique sur au
maillage complet sur le territoire une
forte synergie entre EDF et GDF un
programme nucléaire qui avait fait ses
preuves une indépendance qui nous avait
d'ailleurs permis de participer à la
solidarité européenne y compris en
exportant auprès des pays dans le besoin
cependant ce modèle est aujourd'hui
fragilisé et vous le savez le déficit de
production d'électricité d'origine
nucléaire que nous connaissons
actuellement avec l'arrêt à cette heure
encore de 23 réacteurs sur 56 s'il le
fait de carénage et le fruit de de
sous-investissement chronique est aussi
le fruit de renoncement alors que faire
dans ce contexte le gouvernement nous
propose d'inverser les sujets et des
débats au lieu de discuter du plan nous
travaillons d'abord à ces détails avec
le projet de loi visant à accélérer les
EnR autrement dit alors que nous
manquons de sécurité sur
l'approvisionnement pour équilibrer
l'équilibre offre demande nous cherchons
à développer des moyens non pilotables
en urgence sans plan sans stratégie et
surtout sans maîtrise publique car si
nous savons qu'il est essentiel de
développer un mix énergétique et
équilibré diversifié qui rattrape le
retard pris par le pays sur ce point
nous avons besoin d'un développement
public planifié exemplaire concerté
intégrant les conflits d'usage à terre
comme en mer c'est évidemment une
préoccupation majeure que nous formulons
hors depuis de nombreuses années la
montée en puissance des ENR s'est fait
au détriment de l'emprein local de
l'industrie made in France et de cette
maîtrise que nous attendons nourri
appuyé par l'obligation d'achat le
complément de rémunération les EnR ont
ainsi pu largement bénéficié d'un
soutien public sans jamais que la
Commission européenne d'ailleurs n'y
trouve rien n'a redire des dizaines de
milliards d'euros ont ainsi permis à
tous les porteurs projets privés
d'investir nos paysages la montée en
puissance des ENR s'est faite sans
planification un développement
anarchique qui a répondu à une seule
logique celle du marché les porteurs de
projets ont développé ainsi la plus
rentable et la plus facile exemple
l'éolien plutôt que la géothermie les
porteurs de projets ont également fait
le choix de concentrer les installations
là où la rentabilité est la plus
évidente la plus immédiate chez les
pauvres Hauts-de-France Grand Est au
nord de la Seine-Maritime ou la
saturation commence à se faire jour une
logique qui a suivi également l'éolien
en mer l'exemple parfait de ce que le
marché peut faire à nos écosystèmes
marins en mépris total à la volonté des
élus des pêcheurs et celui du projet au
large du Tréport un constat que semblé
partagé à l'époque Emmanuel Macron qui
avait déclaré le 14 janvier 2020 à Pau
lors d'une table ronde que la capacité à
développer massivement l'éolien et
réduite insistant sur le fait le
consensus sur l'éolien est en train de
nettement s'affaiblir dans notre pays
disait le président de la République la
première ministre alors ministre de la
transition énergétique une semaine après
poursuivait le développement de l'éolien
est très mal réparti en France rappelant
que cela s'est fait de façon anarchique
et on a des territoires dans lesquels il
y a une saturation y compris visuel il
existait alors un consensus pour dire
que ce développement s'était fait sans
maîtrise publique ni structuration des
filières françaises au détriment des
paysages au détriment de notre
patrimoine et surtout de notre économie
puisque la majorité des producteurs
d'éoliens sont situés outre-reins et que
l'essentiel du marché photovoltaïque se
fait en Chine une accélération oui mais
laquelle sans véritable plan ne va pas
accélérer grand chose sinon un maître
une fois de plus les mêmes territoires à
contribution au mépris des procédures de
concertation du public de notre
indépendance de la biodiversité comme
l'ont dénoncé des dizaines
d'institutions et d'organisation non
gouvernementales car cette accélération
n'a pas le Light motif réel de ce projet
de loi non ce projet de loi est un
signal au marché en France c'est
désormais open bar au développement son
contrainte des ENR rien ne sera entravé
les VRP des éoliennes des panneaux
solaires car rien n'existe dans ce
projet ou pas grand chose devrait se
dire pour empêcher le développement hors
des zones telles qu'elles sont définies
prioritairement par les maires ce projet
de loi ne revient sur rien et proposons
contraire d'accélérer la mise en miette
de la péréquation tarifaire même si j'ai
cru comprendre qu'un amendement visite à
corriger cela on l'examinera évidemment
avec attention nous alertons je termine
par là
nos collègues y compris l'ensemble des
collègues de gauche qui sont attachés et
de droite qui sont attachées à l'unicité
d'EDF car ce projet peut constituer le
premier levier la première marche le
premier cheval de Troie qui dessine le
retour déguisé d'Hercule de points 0 ce
projet que vous attendez tant pour
démanteler une fois pour toute EDF après
avoir livré des ENR au marché et à la
rentabilité vous allez investir dans les
EPR préparer à la découpe notre fleuron
et si nous passons l'hiver nous au
travers de votre impréparation vous
concoctez un plan qui nous permet de
douter sur le fait que EDF ne peut pas
passer l'hiver le groupe GDR a déposé
une centaine d'amendements qui lisent
à mettre en place des garde-fous à
corriger la copie c'est avec cet état
d'esprit que nous entamons ce débat
passionnant
merci Monsieur jumelles je rappelle dans
le cas de cette discussion générale que
chaque orateur dispose du temps qu'il
souhaite et qu'ensuite c'est des compter
de chaque groupe politique la parole est
à Monsieur Bricout du groupe libertin
indépendant outre-mer et territoire
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mesdames madame et Messieurs
les rapporteurs mais mes chers collègues
alors je voudrais d'abord
aborder le sujet sur sur la forme
souligner vous l'avez souligné madame la
ministre effectivement
moi j'ai trouvé que dans la Commission
et dans les échanges qu'on a pu avoir en
aparté une certaine qualité de ces
échanges une certaine écoute même ça
nous a permis quelque part de mieux
évaluer les enjeux de mieux peser en fin
de compte les difficultés qu'on peut
avoir sur nos territoires même si
quelquefois enfin nous on l'aborder en
tous les cas d'un dans un esprit très
constructif même si quelquefois votre
niveau d'acceptation de propositions
nous convient pas complètement mais je
ne désespère pas Madame le Ministre en
tous les cas on a cet esprit constructif
deuxième point sur sur la forme c'est
effectivement et ça a été rappelé par un
mon collègue monsieur Jumel le problème
de temporalité des textes on a
l'impression de parler du contenant
avant de parler du contenu je crois que
ça pose problème on fait un petit peu
les choses à l'envers je crois qu'il
aurait été plus intelligent de
effectivement définir nos objectifs au
niveau de la PPE et puis de pouvoir
après parler de la méthode la méthode
pour essayer d'aller plus vite et de
réaliser ses objectifs et les
dispositions qu'il faut prendre pour
arriver arriver aux résultats pour
revenir sur le fond du texte moi je
m'attarderai sur deux points simplement
sur la planification en particulier et
sur l'éolien terrestre qui pose
effectivement des problèmes sur notre
territoire je crois que on est
quelques-uns à s'en soucier aujourd'hui
madame la ministre le constat est clair
on est les derniers élèves du de
l'Europe
pour un pays qui quelquefois et un
président qui donne des leçons à
l'Europe des leçons au monde entier je
dois avouer que ça fait un petit peu
désordre d'être mauvais élève en fin de
compte en matière de production des
énergies renouvelables et c'est bien
dommage et comme je disais je pense que
on aurait préféré avoir un ordre du
texte qui soit dans enfin que le texte
dans le bon ordre à partir de ce conseil
évidemment on ne peut que
c'est difficile quelque part de se poser
au texte sur les objectifs en tous les
cas de ce texte ici et là bien sûr on
entend quelques divergences par rapport
au sujet du nucléaire mais je crois
qu'il faut pas perdre de vue de choses
qui sont de toute façon sûr c'est que le
nucléaire si on doit le développer ben
c'est pas avant 10 ans par contre
l'usage électrique l'électrification des
usages c'est tout de suite donc à partir
de là le texte je pense que ce soit au
niveau de notre groupe que ce soit au
niveau quelquefois des populations on
voit bien qu'il faut de toute façon
accélérer cette description de l'éolien
le problème jusque là je vais dire tout
va bien mais c'est quand on arrive dans
la déclinaison son au territoire la
déclinaison des objectifs que là ça
commence à poser problème effectivement
on parle de d'augmenter la production
d'avoir des nouveaux projets sur des
territoires qui sont déjà saturés qui
sont déjà saturation où il y a un niveau
d'acceptabilité important
d'inacceptabilité importante pardon
quand on a des nouveaux projets qui
viennent qui provoquent une espèce
d'encerclement de nos villages qui
provoque un bitage des territoires qui
qui viennent quelque part en
confrontation par rapport à notre projet
de territoire qui est souvent basé sur
sur le tourisme sur la culture qui
viennent heurter aussi nos paysages
évidemment ça ça pose problème et madame
la ministre il y a une chose qui est
sûre c'est si on veut obtenir les
objectifs vous pourrez pas le faire sans
les territoires c'est pas possible et
faire avec les territoires
c'est d'abord respecter les territoires
c'est respecter ses élus respecter ces
populations respecter ses paysages
respecter ses projets
pardon ce que nous demandons en fin de
compte vous l'avez rappelé vous semblez
avoir réussi à nous convaincre mais je
crois qu'il le texte est pas complet il
manque il y a encore quelques garde-fous
à voir ce qu'on demande son au
territoire c'est tout simplement que les
élus la population est simplement la
parole et donc je pense que votre texte
doit pas tout à fait au bout même s'il y
a des dispositions qui sont
intéressantes ce qu'on veut sur nos
territoires c'est dire oui quand c'est
nécessaire et pouvoir dire non avoir
notamment les les dispositions
juridiques et dispositions qui sont
opposables juridiquement pour pouvoir
dit non quand c'est nécessaire de dire
non donc laisser je pense qu'il faut
laisser aux élus laisser la population
c'est responsabilités on est capable de
savoir faire sur votre territoire ce
qu'on veut c'est pouvoir refuser des
projets je vous l'ai dit quand c'est
quand des projets ne sont pas tout
simplement partagés quand ils sont pas
quand ils ne sont pas désirés tout
simplement sur notre territoire
alors on vous a proposé quelques
dispositions c'est venu d'ailleurs sur
plusieurs bancs de même de l'opposition
je crois qu'il y avait Delphine bateau
qui avait proposé enfin qui propose
toujours d'ailleurs de définir un indice
de saturation visuelle je pense que ça
peut faire partie des éléments qui
peuvent être entendus ou qui peuvent
être dans tous les cas expertiser moi je
vous ai proposé de définir un taux
d'effort en deux mots c'est de se dire à
partir du moment on a des objectifs
régionaux de pouvoir les décliner sur
une communauté de communes et une fois
qu'on a rempli ces objectifs on a même
proposé 10% de plus évolutifs de pouvoir
dire non en disant bah maintenant si
c'est bien on le fera si ça pose
problème sur notre territoire qu'on est
le moyen juridique opposable de pouvoir
qu'on puisse s'opposer en fin de compte
à ces projets on avait on vous a proposé
aussi d'adosser en fin de compte les
zonages dans les différents documents
d'urbanisme alors c'est fait pour les
PLU pour les pluies pour les pour les
scottes mais vous sur nos territoires on
a des villages qui sont encore en NRU ou
qui sont en carte communale et là on
peut pas adosser ces documents donc ça
c'est un vrai problème parce que ça
empêche encore une fois de pouvoir
s'opposer en fin de compte à certains
projets
et puis on vous a proposé aussi en fin
de compte de conjuguer les dispositions
qui avaient été prises dans la loi 3DS
c'était dans le précédent mandat et les
zonages qui sont définis maintenant dans
ce nouveau projet de loi notamment qu'on
puisse non seulement avoir des zones
d'accélération sur nos territoires mais
qu'on puisse avoir aussi des zones
d'exclusion pour encore une fois pour
voir dire non quand c'est tout
simplement le bon moment donc alors moi
je sais pas qui m'en remettre si je dois
m'en remettre au dieu Éole le dieu des
vents ou à madame la ministre mais en
tous les cas je crois qu'il faut
absolument que vous vous assuriez que
nos territoires sont bien respectés et
quoi qu'il en soit moi je vous le dis
clairement moi je savais je suis dans
les hauts de France mon territoire c'est
la tirage c'est un pays bocagé et ça ne
deviendra pas le pays des Télétubbies
avec des éoliennes un peu partout donc
soyez vigilante sur nos propositions
soyez attentifs à nos territoires
respecter les
je vais terminer parce que le reste du
texte c'est ma collègue Nathalie Bazire
qui bâtir qui qui
abordera les différents sujets notamment
la grivevoltaïsme où là aussi il y a des
points de vigilance on voit bien que
c'est un des projets qui sont quand même
plutôt favorables qui sont plutôt bien
disant aux opérateurs qui répercutent
qui répercute en fin de compte cette
bien-dixence sur sur les agriculteurs et
j'ai peur qu'encore une fois on est des
dérives des dérives sur lac sur
un développement qui soit anarchique
quelque part ou qu'on ait une envolée
des prix du foncier au détriment
justement nos jeunes agriculteurs voilà
je vous remercie j'espère que vous serez
à notre écoute et que les débats sont
très constructifs et très prometteurs
merci la ministre de la transition
énergétique espère réunir les voies
nécessaires à l'adoption de son texte
mais dans un hémicycle où il n'y a pas
de majorité claire la bataille des
renouvelables et rude les députés de la
droite et le rassemblement national
de leur hostilité à plusieurs mesures du
texte
pendant la campagne présidentielle nous
avions annoncé avec Marine Le Pen que le
fameux discours de Belfort d'Emmanuel
Macron n'était pas un plan de relance du
nucléaire mais une gigantesque promotion
des énergies intermittentes encore une
fois nous avions dit la vérité en
français encore une fois vous leur aviez
menti nous y sommes voilà la loi qui
doit doubler les éoliennes sur terre
dont les Français ne veulent plus voilà
la loi qui doit défigurer nos côtes sauf
au Touquet évidemment avec 50 parcs
d'éoliennes sur mer dont les Français ne
veulent pas voilà la loi qui doit
décupler les panneaux solaires dans les
Français découvriront vite qu'il
produiront bien peu d'énergie mais
qu'ils auront massivement enrichi la
Chine un petit rappel des ordres de
grandeur qui devrait ramener tout le
monde à un peu de rationalité avec
seulement deux petits réacteurs
nucléaires français nous produisons plus
d'électricité que l'ensemble des
panneaux solaires qui recouvrent le
territoire depuis 2019
le calendrier parlementaire traduit en
fait la réalité de vos priorités mais
surtout de vos obsessions l'application
systématique et aveugle des décisions
européennes pardon des décisions
allemandes madame panier runacher malgré
leur effet non malgré le fait que nous
payons aujourd'hui leur facture terrible
vous prétendez avoir tiré les leçons de
l'effondrement de la souveraineté
énergétique française et européenne mais
vous aggrave avec cette loi les erreurs
qui nous ont conduit vous pouvez
accumuler sans cesse sur un territoire
comme la France ou même sur un
territoire comme l'Europe autant de
gigawatts d'énergie intermittente que
vous le souhaitez vous nous résoudrez
jamais nos problèmes d'approvisionnement
jamais le soleil de janvier ne vous
aidera à passer les dures mois de
l'hiver encore moins évidemment la
lumière de la lune jamais le grand froid
ne sera combattu avec des éoliennes
puisque ces périodes sont
systématiquement liées à des faibles
vents
quel manque d'humilité vous pouvez avoir
dans ce gouvernement et dans la
Commission européenne pour avoir oublié
les lois si évidentes de la nature loi
que nous avons pourtant mis des
millénaires à apprivoiser quel manque de
rationalité faut-il que vous ayez pour
que le continent de naissance du
raisonnement scientifique lui-même soit
paralysé par des bouffées délirantes
faisant faire n'importe quoi à ceux qui
devraient nous protéger si l'énergie du
soleil et du vent avait pu produire le
niveau de vie et le confort des sociétés
industrielles l'humanité n'aurait pas
souffert mille martyrs pendant la quasi
totalité de son histoire il est temps
que vous cessiez de vivre dans un déni
de ce que la technologie peut faire des
lois de la physique que vous que ne
comprenez-vous pas dans le mot
intermittent que ne comprenez-vous pas
dans l'effet qu'aucune solution de
stockage massif n'existe et n'existera
de notre vivant encore ce matin à 8h les
panneaux solaires français
fonctionnaient à moins de 5% de leur
taux de charge les éoliennes françaises
tocard le nucléaire
malade même profondément malade
fonctionnait à 60% de son taux de charge
vous pouvez développer encore plus les
énergies intermittentes jamais au
combien jamais elle ne paye permettront
de rompre avec les énergies fossiles au
contraire plus vous développerez les
énergies intermittentes plus vous nous
lirez aux énergies fossiles en
particulier au gaz elle fonctionne de
pairs elles ont toutes leurs fonctionné
de père les industriels savent qu'elles
fonctionnent de pairs les lobbies savent
qu'elles fonctionnent de pairs et la
Russie qui vous a piéger savait qu'elle
fonctionnait de pair si vous aviez été
sincère nous aurions déjà modifié les
textes depuis 20 ans qui en France en
particulier sous François Hollande en
particulier évidemment sous le premier
quinquennat de Macron ont toujours prévu
et ont toujours encore prévu aujourd'hui
de fermer 12 réacteurs nucléaires vous
n'avez pas fait les choses dans l'ordre
ce texte est aujourd'hui non pertinent
comme l’on dit nos collègues il faut
évidemment revoir avant tout la PPE
revoir le cadre réglementaire et les
législatif que vous avez fixés avant de
savoir quelles énergies nous voulons
développer dans ce cadre réglementaire
mais vous faites les choses dans vous
faites les choses à l'inverse mais en
fait non vous le faites les choses dans
l'ordre l'ordre de l'Allemagne et
l'ordre de l'Union européenne si vous ne
voulez pas changer le cadre législatif
français européen avant d'envisager la
façon dont vous dont vous voulez pardon
déployer les énergies c'est qu'en fait
vous appliquez la feuille de route qui a
été celle avant la crise énergétique que
nous traversons aujourd'hui vous pouvez
parler matin à midi et soir de la
tragédie ukrainienne vous pouvez parler
matin midi et soir de la crise
énergétique actuelle ou de celle que
nous traversons depuis le covid en
réalité vous n'avez tenu aucune leçon
retenue aucune leçon de ces périodes
vous appliquez la règle qui a été fixée
par l'Union européenne il y a bien
longtemps vous continuez à fixer cette
règle le fait que l'Allemagne avec les
500 milliards d'euros qu'elle a brûlé
dans les nerfs given 2 et était un crash
test à ciel ouvert ne vous ne vous a pas
atteint vous continuez à l'appliquer
votre cadre sans aucune autre raison que
l'idéologie prévoit toujours de baisser
le éclair à 50%, d'où sort madame panier
renacher ce chiffre magique en quoi
faudrait-il comme par magie que nous
devions atteindre 50% d'énergie
d'origine d'électricité d'origine
nucléaire ce sont les lois de la
physique qui ont prévu 50% non ce sont
les lois allemandes de l'Union
européenne et ce sont celles auxquelles
vous êtes soumis il y a bien longtemps
avec l'écologie politique le cadre que
vous voulez apposer à la France prévoit
toujours de survaloriser les éoliennes
alors qu'elles ne fonctionnent pas vous
prévoyez toujours de survaler les
éoliennes en mer alors qu'elles n'ont
pas fonctionné dans les pays voisins
nous le voyons aujourd'hui à l'inverse à
l'inverse vous méprisez vous méprisez
systématiquement avec le même avec le
mort d'ailleurs les énergies
renouvelables qui pourraient fonctionner
ce sont les énergies renouvelables que
nous promouvons au rassemblement
national avec Marine Le Pen pourquoi ne
déployez-vous pas tout ce que nous
pouvons faire comme potentiel
hydroélectrique vous refusez d'aborder
ce débat je remarque que la voix du
nucléaire a enfin parlé du déploiement
des steppes qui avaient parlé du
déploiement des stations de pompage
classique pendant la présidentielle
c'est Marine Le Pen et personne d'autre
je vois que vous refusez toujours de
parler du développement massif de la
géothermie qui en avait parlé comme
énergie renouvelable c'est Marine Le Pen
je vois que vous avez enfin timidement
commencer à parler d'hydrogène même si
les actes ne suivent pas qui a parlé
d'hydrogène depuis 2005 c'est Marine Le
Pen donc en fait cette loi cette loi
n'est pas le procès des énergies
renouvelables cette loi est le procès
des énergies stupides et aveugle que
vous continuez à imposer aux français
malgré vos échecs malgré les factures
cette loi une fois plus je le dis est
une loi idéologique c'est une loi
obsolète mais c'est surtout une loi
cynique c'est le cynisme propre à la
macronie vous retournez systématiquement
les aspirations des Français contre même
vous leur faisez miracle miroiter
quelques réacteurs nucléaires pour faire
diversion pour imposer des milliers de
mayoliennes sur terre et en mer des
milliers de panneaux photovoltaïques
vous faites miroiter aux Français une
c'est condamné toute vraie transition
énergétique pour lier notre destin au
gaz russe et au gaz
qatari c'est condamner les Français à la
précarité énergétique c'est condamner
les Français à la pauvreté organisée
cette loi n'est pas mauvaise elle lui
suicidaire et donc nous la combattrons
merci Monsieur Tanguy en cette saison
hivernale la question des coupures de
courant s'invite dans l'hémicycle
certains députés profitent de la tribune
offerte par la discussion générale pour
dénoncer l'impréparation du gouvernement
dans la gestion de la crise énergétique
les Français vivront cet hiver une
véritable angoisse celle de voir leur
pays grande puissance mondiale autrefois
leader de l'électricité décarbonée
relégué au rang non seulement des
importateurs mais des plus exposés au
risque de rupture d'approvisionnement
madame la ministre vous devez l'assumer
car cela fait pardon car cela fait 10
ans que votre idéologie est au pouvoir
disant de démantèlement de notre filière
d'excellence de super Phénix au projet
d'Astrid en passant naturellement par la
fermeture de Fessenheim 10 ans de
subventions massive à une électricité
intermittente 10 ans de désarmement face
aux défis climatique énergétique où nous
étions pourtant les leaders mondiaux
grâce à une industrie nucléaire
florissante que le monde entier nous
enviait vous nous dites que les énergies
nous renouvelables sont en train de
rembourser les investissements publics
pharaoniques dont elles ont bénéficié
pourtant le compte n'y est pas le
montant total des engagements pris pour
le soutien aux énergies renouvelables et
estimées entre 120 et 150 milliards
d'euros alors que les recettes estimées
par la crue à l'occasion de cette hausse
des prix insupportable pour les Français
sont à peine 31 milliards d'euros
l'argent de cette fameuse rente vient
directement d'une ponction sur le
pouvoir d'achat des Français qui a fondu
face à l'explosion du prix de
l'électricité dont est responsable cette
mauvaise politique qui génère de la
rareté vous nous parlez de l'objectif
des 23% d'énergie renouvelable imposée
par l'Union européenne que nous n'avons
pas atteint mais qu'avez-vous fait pour
le remettre en cause lors de ces
révisions successives de 2018 et 2022 où
étiez-vous pour faire entendre la voix
de la France et obtenir un objectif
d'énergie bas carbone au lieu de cet
objectif trompeur d'énergie renouvelable
oui cet objectif d'énergie renouvelable
et trompeur mes chers collègues
renouvelables ne veut pas dire bon pour
le climat la principale énergie qui a
permis d'atteindre cet objectif en 2020
c'est la biomasse autrement dit du bois
et du gaz que l'on brûle tous les pays
n'ont pas été logés à la même enseigne
pour atteindre les 20% l'échelle de
l'Europe on a demandé 23% la France et
18% l'Allemagne chers collègues où est
la justice où est l'équité lorsque nous
avons raté notre objectif de 2020 on a
fini à
19,1% d'énergie renouvelable contre
19,3% pour les Allemands quasiment vous
l'avouerez au même niveau donc arrêtons
le taux flagellation parce que dans le
même temps nos voisins émettent deux
fois plus de carbone par habitant que
nous en plus de réchauffer l'atmosphère
cela cause des dizaines de morts par an
y compris sur notre sol
le groupe LR a été extrêmement clair ce
qui constitue des points d'ouverture la
distance d'éloignement des éoliennes à
la fois sur terre et sur mer en étain le
saccage de nos compagnes de nos
campagnes pardon par ses aérogénérateurs
de plus en plus massifs ne peut plus
continuer nos monuments historiques
notre littoral notre ligne d'horizon
font la très touristique de nos
territoires et du cadre de vie dont nous
sommes je crois tous collectivement très
fiers à l'heure où la Chine développe
des éoliennes offshore de 16 mégawatts
et de 270 mètres de haut il est
essentiel de mieux protéger notre
patrimoine paysager commun témoignage de
notre belle histoire vous essayez de
nous rassurer en disant que seul 1% du
territoire national serait concerné par
les éoliennes suite à ce texte mais un
pour cent mes chers collègues c'est
énorme c'est l'équivalent d'un
département 50 fois plus que la surface
de Paris s'était frayant un autre point
de négociation aurait pu être le rôle
des élus qui doit renforcé vous nous
proposez de définir des zones
d'accélération en accord avec les mers
mais leur définition et leur validation
nécessiteront plusieurs mois voire des
années de procédures pendant ce temps il
en attendant leur entrée en vigueur des
milliers d'éoliennes continueront d'être
installés sans aucun droit de regard des
conseils municipaux vous ne souhaitez
pas modifier le code de l'environnement
pour entendre la voix des territoires
nous continuerons de la porter pendant
les discussions qui commencent ce soir
dans ces conditions et pour toutes ces
raisons nous aborderons l'examen du
texte avec beaucoup de vigilance
notamment sur sa principale mesure
l'instauration sans attendre la mise en
place des zones d'accélération en
concertation avec les conseils
municipaux de la fameuse raison
impérative d'intérêt public majeurs ici
il s'agit là rien de moins que d'écraser
le droit commun et accessoirement
d'écraser la faune et la flore au profit
d'une industrie largement étrangère pour
remplir des objectifs injustes et sans
lien avec le climat pour le groupe les
républicains le vrai intérêt public
majeur c'est de réindustrialiser la
France mes chers collègues accélérons la
relocalisation du textile de
l'automobile de la sidérurgie de
l'industrie made in France rien
industriels la France s'est évité le
carbone induit par la production des
pays fortement en retard en termes
d'empreintes carbone vous le voyez
madame la ministre vous devez entendre
nos arguments et ne pas franchir ces
lignes rouges si vous souhaitez
recueillir notre soutien sur ce texte
dans le cadre contraire vous assumerez
la responsabilité de la colère des
Français qui se rendent compte de
l'impasse dans laquelle notre pays est
plongé par de telles politiques motivées
par une idéologie qui nous a déjà
conduit à l'échec je vous en remercie
merci Monsieur Maquet le projet de loi
soumis au député contient des
dérogations pour permettre
l'installation de dispositifs d'énergie
renouvelable dans des espaces naturels
le gouvernement assure que son texte ne
va pas sacrifier la biodiversité au
profit du climat mais certains ont des
craintes il n'y a pas à choisir entre
biodiversité et énergies renouvelable
ces deux enjeux sont d'une égale
importance c'est toujours la
biodiversité qui a trinqué dans tout nos
choix jusqu'à aujourd'hui et il y a
aujourd'hui dans cette musique des
nouveaux amis opportunistes de la
biodiversité qui pour s'opposer à
certaines énergies renouvelables iront
défendre la biodiversité mais qui très
rapidement sur d'autres sujets la foule
ronde de leurs pieds et feront le choix
d'aller finalement vers plus
d'artificialisation et plus de
destruction de la biodiversité nous
refuser tout agrigvoltaïsme qui
artificialise les sols et nuit à notre
souveraineté alimentaire nous refuserons
les contrats d'achat d'électricité les
fameux PPA grâce auxquels Google
s'approprie déjà des éoliennes dans la
mer du Nord nous refuserons les
bidouilles sur les factures
d'électricité nous refuserons enfin le
retour de la raison impérative
d'intérêts publics majeurs sans les
garanties que nous avons demandé en
commission voilà quelques lignes claires
de fractures avec votre vision et avec
ce projet de loi mais nous ne nous en
tiendrons pas là puisque nous
proposerons par amendement de nombreuses
mesures pour une meilleure planification
des renouvelables nous porterons avec
les députés de mon groupe des
propositions pour les outre-mer qui
peuvent être le fer de lance de cette
ambition du 100% énergies renouvelable
nous porterons celle des protecteurs de
la biodiversité et enfin nous porterons
celles des Français qui souhaitent
participer à des débats physiquement à
côté de chez eux nous ferons au mieux
pour que ce texte intègre les
dispositions indispensables pour la
concertation citoyenne la protection des
filières industrielles le le public de
ce secteur et des moyens suffisants pour
l'État nous amendrons également pour que
les zones déjà artificialisées les
parkings les toitures les délaissés
autoroutiers notamment permettent
prioritairement l'accélération dont nous
avons besoin en résumé madame la
ministre les Français ont froid ils
n'ont plus le temps pour vos petits pas
soyez à la hauteur et revoyez votre
copie le mot éolien ne figure plus en
tant que tel dans le projet de loi du
gouvernement il est pourtant omniprésent
dans les débats et monopolise le temps
de parole des députés la séance est
ouverte
bonsoir l'ordre du jour appelle la suite
de la discussion du projet de loi
relatif à l'accélération de la
production d'énergie renouvelable hier
soir l'assemblée poursuivi l'examen des
articles s'arrêtant à l'article 1er ca
nous avons donc nous allons donc
continuer avec un article supprimé il
n'y a pas d'inscription d'orateur qui
est possible sur cet article supprimé
mais nous avons une série d'amendements
qui vont être soumis à une discussion
commune et j'ouvre cette discussion
commune avec l'amendement 28 63 qui est
présenté monsieur Vermorel marquez c'est
vous qui le présentez et vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur je vais un par cet amendement
vous inviter à respecter l'engagement du
président de la République qui en mai
2019 devant un parterre d'architectes
affirmé je cite je veux offrir à
l'architecture une place toute
particulière en associant les
architectes aux deux défis avec lesquels
nous avons à vivre que sont la lutte
contre la fracture territoriale et le
réchauffement climatique par cet
amendement nous souhaitons demander aux
architectes de bâtiments de France de
pouvoir donner un avis conforme comme le
Sénat l'avait souhaité pour les projets
éoliens à proximité des monuments
historiques et c'est le but de cet
amendement de rétablir cet article qui
avait été mis en place à nos amis
sénateurs merci beaucoup merci monsieur
le député l'amendement 855 monsieur
Dupont-Aignan oui monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre
mon amendement vise à
obliger un avis conforme de l'architecte
des bâtiments de France à 20 km de tout
installation donc c'est un peu plus que
l'amendement qui avait été de l'article
qui avait été voté par le Sénat parce
que véritablement il faut que vous
disiez la vérité aux Français
7 ce projet de loi vise à doubler au
moins le nombre des éoliennes on est
bien d'accord doublé le nombre
d'éoliennes avec des éoliennes qui
désormais font près de 200 mètres de
haut c'est massacrer notre territoire et
un jour vos petits-enfants vous qui
prétendez défendre l'environnement
s'interrogeront et vous demanderont
comment se fait-il que vous vouliez
défendre l'environnement sauver la
planète et que vous ayez massacré
saccager l'un des plus beaux pays de la
planète l'un des joyaux de la planète
vous avez déjà massacré la montagne
Sainte-Victoire 22 éoliennes dans une
zone Natura 2000 sans exploitation
autorisation environnementale
d'exploitation vous êtes en train de
massacrer la baie de Saint-Brieuc vous
êtes en train de massacrer les lieux
partout en France des projets sont dans
les cartons il faut que les Français
sachent ce soir que si ce projet passe
cela veut dire au moins
l'éolienne aussi haute que la tour
Montparnasse qui vont être répartis sur
l'ensemble du territoire alors ça vous
gêne parce que il y a des résistances
parce que les Français protestent parce
que même Stéphane Bern Stéphane Bern
pas un opposant du macronisme Stéphane
Bern a dit très justement c'est un
diktat éolien qui brasse du vent et
ancre dans nos sols un véritable
mensonge comment le pays première
destination touristique mondiale qui
ambitionne s'il vous plaît
par an peut-il à ce point s'aborder cet
atout magnifique pensez à tous ces
paysages ces monuments historiques
arrêtez ce massacre
merci monsieur le député chers collègues
si vous voulez vous interpeller parler
de la baie de Saint-Brieuc vous le ferez
ou pendant le débat ou à l'extérieur
mais je propose qu'on continue à écouter
Nicolas Dupont-Aignan sur l'amendement
et bien je vais très bref pour pas
gaspiller mon temps de parole puisque
c'est un amendement de repli a 10 km
plutôt que 20 bien merci monsieur le
député nous avons maintenant des
amendements
identiques le 52 est-ce qu'il est
défendu je ne vois pas Madame Antoine le
117 qui le présente c'est Vincent des
cœurs allez-y merci monsieur le
Président c'est amendement qui vise à
rétablir l'article
1 ca supprimer en commission propose de
fait de réintroduire la vie conforme de
l'architecte des bâtiments de France
s'agissant de l'éolienne terrestre et de
s'assurer ainsi qu'aucun projet ne
viendra impacter visuellement
l'environnement d'un monument inscrit ou
protégé c'est un amendement de bon sens
merci Monsieur Deckers le 151 qu'il
présente monsieur neuder
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
le présente amendement s'inscrit dans la
dans le même rôle de réhabiliter les
bâtiments de France notamment sur les
projets éoliens de grands dimensions à
proximité des monuments historiques ou à
proximité d'éléments patrimoniaux c'est
amendement avait été déjà porté par le
Sénat il a été retiré au fait que 46 000
monuments historiques rendraient
impossible l'installation d'éoliennes il
est important de repréciser que ces 46
000 bâtiments une grande partie sont
situées notamment en zone
urbaine notamment dans les métropoles ce
qui rend deux facto impossibles
l'installation d'éoliennes donc nous
souhaitons effectivement préserver nos
paysages et nos territoires ruraux et
faire en sorte que les bâtiments de
France puissent exprimer leur demande
pour conforter la vie des mers merci
merci monsieur le député nous passons
159 Jean-Pierre Vigier oui merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
nous avons un patrimoine bâti inscrit au
glacier de très grande qualité et qui
fait vivre nos territoires notamment nos
territoires ruraux et je vous prends un
seul exemple ce sont les villages
classés plus beaux villages de France
imaginez que c'est plus beau village et
des éoliennes aux abords et ben tout
simplement à travers cet amendement Oran
l'avis de la BF conforme pour qu'il
donne son avis sur l'installation le
projet d'installation d'un lien dans un
périmètre de 10 km c'est un amendement
de bon sens merci madame la ministre
merci monsieur le député le 299
il est défendu merci Monsieur minot le
alors est-ce que Monsieur Cordillot
monsieur signérrier là non donc il n'est
pas défendu le 857 ceux du pont-aignan
défendu le 1414 monsieur villefrande
défendu
le
[Musique]
2297 monsieur boucar est là non il n'est
pas défendu le
2941 je ne vois c'est voilà Monsieur
Bouix
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
sur cet amendement pour rejoindre
certains de mes collègues je crois tout
simplement qu'il est important de
prendre en compte ces conditions c'est
considérations esthétiques et finalement
l'architecte des bâtiments de France il
est aussi garant de ces conditions
esthétiques c'est un peu comme si
finalement
et bien vous alliez au musée du Louvre
voire une oeuvre je prends par exemple
la Joconde et que vous vous retrouveriez
en face de cette œuvre et qu'on ait
subitement installé un compteur
électrique je pense que on serait dans
une situation effectivement à ce moment
précis où ces conditions esthétiques
prennent alors tout leur sens
aujourd'hui la France c'est un
patrimoine architectural et je pense que
cet avis des bâtiments de France doit
nous permettre de défendre ce patrimoine
merci monsieur le député nous passons à
une autre série d'amendements
identiques en passant en commençant par
le 1084 monsieur Deckers merci monsieur
le Président toujours s'agissant de la
consultation de
l'architecte des bâtiments de France
cette amendement visa réintroduire le
principe d'une délimitation d'un
périmètre de 10 km une distance d'autant
plus légitime que la hauteur des
éoliennes ne cesse de croître
merci monsieur le député le 12 71 est-ce
que monsieur neuder veut le défendre
défendu le 16 03
madame louvagi
défendu le 18-21 madame Bazin malgrande
n'est pas là non il n'est pas défendu
monsieur minot le 29 48
allez-y Monsieur patriotus Merci
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
notre patrimoine est un bien commun
précieux que nous devons entretenir et
préserver mais il est déjà fragile et
les monuments historiques des
territoires en particulier sont déjà
trop souvent oubliés mis au second plan
mal entretenu alors chers collègues
n'ajoutons pas cette fragilité des
dégradations visuelles supplémentaires
qui pourraient nuire à ce patrimoine
local l'objectif d'accélérer
l'implantation d'énergie renouvelable
n'est pas en contradiction avec celui de
protéger de mettre en valeur ce bien
commun précieux qu'un autre patrimoine
bâti et paysager au contraire ces deux
objectifs doivent cohabiter l'amendement
que je porte avec mon collègue Thierry
Benoît propose en effet une nouvelle
écriture de l'ancien article premier ca
plus souple elle permet d'adapter le
périmètre dans lequel versera la vie
conforme des ABS seuls les zones
entourant les monuments historiques
offrant une perspective monumentale ou
une vue particulièrement remarquable
seront prises en compte
il est en effet légitime de ne pas
imposer un périmètre fixe de 10 km dans
lequel s'exercerait cet avis conforme si
les réalités du terrain ne l'exigent pas
il n'y aurait par exemple aucun intérêt
patrimonial à un tel périmètre pour un
monument cerné de forêt ou de collines
qui ne présenteraient aucun cas de
covidbilité avec les éoliennes néanmoins
cette extension du périmètre est
indispensable contenu de la taille des
éoliennes de nouvelle générations
atteignant jusqu'à plus de 240 mètres de
hauteur certaines peuvent être visibles
à plus de 30 km la loi doit donc évoluer
pour s'adapter à ces données nouvelles
je souhaite qu'elle évolue dans un
esprit de conciliation entre la
protection du patrimoine et l'urgence
écologique et énergétique et c'est
pourquoi cette nouvelle version de
l'article prévoit la possibilité
d'exercer un recourir archique contre la
vie conforme devant le Préfet de Région
qui devra départager ces deux intérêts
vous l'aurez compris mes chers collègues
le respect de la vie conforme des ABS
n'est donc pas une entrave il évite la
naissance de projets qui ne peuvent
qu'être refusés par les populations
locales attachées à leur patrimoine
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
député
je poursuis sur les amendements le 10 90
qui le défend en groupe Rennes
il est défendu merci Monsieur Tanguy le
21/11 je ne vois pas de cosignataire
il n'est pas défendu visiblement non
plus on repasse sur des amendements
identiques avec l'amendement 180
monsieur
[Musique]
c'est Madame Bonnivard
allez-y
si je comprends l'intention du projet de
loi en revanche je ne peux pas partager
comme rapporteur du budget du tourisme
l'impact qu'il aurait puisque le projet
de loi conduirait à couvrir un
département français d'éoliennes c'est
en pour cent du territoire national
c'est considérable c'est 55 fois la
ville de Paris ça signifie ou ou
aboutirait sur quel territoire quel
territoire français serait dévisagé par
ce projet de loi comme rapporteur du
budget du tourisme j'y suis très
attentive et notamment sur le joyau que
représente le patrimoine architectural
et naturel français qui constitue un
atout d'attractivité majeur de la
destination France c'est donc un
amendement de repli par rapport aux
amendements précédents qui vise à
apporter à 500 5 km pardon le rayon pour
lequel il faut un avis transforme de
l'architecte des bâtiments de France
pour pouvoir installer des éoliennes
merci madame la députée l'amendement 561
monsieur Deckers
il s'agit d'un amendement de repli qui
prévoit des temps de la vie conforme de
la BF au projet de parc éolien de
grandes dimensions qui entre dans le
champ de visibilité d'un monument
historique ou d'un site patrimonial et
en retenant cette fois-ci un périmètre
de 5 km autour de ceci
merci monsieur le député
l'amendement 640 n'est pas défendue le
11 86 monsieur Bourgeot
mes collègues viennent très bien de la
défendre et donc voilà défendu
parfait merci Michel deuté le 13 39
je ne vois pas Nantes se relance vous
n'êtes pas qu'aux signataire
je ne vois pas de CO signataires donc il
n'est pas défendu mais le 13 73 c'est
vous merci monsieur le Président c'est
l'idée qu'il faut soumettre un avis
conforme des architectes des bâtiments
de France pour l'installation d'éolienne
terrestre cela semble tomber sous le
coup du bon sens il s'agit d'un
amendement qui vise à retravailler un
article voté par les sénateurs qui
étaient supprimés en commission dans nos
villes et villages lorsque les
périmètres sont classés souvent pour
quelques travaux il faut un habit
conforme donc on imagine bien que pour
des éoliennes cela va de même et le
périmètre proposé c'est une un chemin
qui est fait vers le gouvernement c'est
5 km non plus 10 km
merci Monsieur Roland l'amendement 15-17
monsieur brigand bienvenue
conforme des bâtiments de France pour
protéger nos sites remarquables et les
monuments historiques les 10 km et puis
je me permets de rajouter qu'en février
2020 Madame Élisabeth borne alors
ministre de la transition écologique et
solidaire déclarait le développement
anarchique de l'éolien terrestre ça
l'étonnait qu'on ait pu autoriser
l'implantation de parc éolien en
convossibilité avec des monuments
historiques donc mon amendement va tout
à fait dans la remarque de Madame borne
de l'époque merci monsieur le député le
1763 n'est pas défendu le 2013 qu'il
défend Emmanuel Maquet allez-y oui merci
monsieur le Président il s'agit là en
quelque sorte de respecter ce qu'a voulu
André Malraux lorsqu'il a souhaité
mettre en place tout le dispositif de
protection du patrimoine de notre pays
de l'ADN de notre pays du respect de
l'histoire de notre pays et donc c'est
évidemment un amendement extrêmement
important si l'on veut porter l'histoire
de notre pays l'histoire de la France
au-delà de notre propre existence de ne
pas ravager nos territoires et de faire
en sorte comme la comme l'ont rappelé un
centre de mes collègues de faire en
sorte de transmettre notre patrimoine à
nos enfants c'est la mission qui nous
est un parti mais aussi de faire en
sorte que notre pays notre beau pays
reste ce qu'il est quant à son
attractivité touristique je rappelle que
c'est 7% de notre PIB et on ne peut pas
s'en moquer fil rouge du débat
l'installation d'éoliennes suscite des
débats électriques en séance publique
atteinte au patrimoine des formations
des paysages les critiques dans
l'hémicycle fusent certains allant
jusqu'à prédire un massacre à venir des
paysages français extrait de séance
toute question d'équilibre oui il faut
développer faciliter le développement
des énergies renouvelables dans notre
pays mais oui il faut continuer à
préserver absolument les 6% de notre
territoire qui un site ou un patrimoine
remarquable d'où ces territoires doux
pour ces territoires le maintien
impératif de la vie conforme de
l'architecte des bâtiments de France que
l'on peut encore faciliter en reculant
sur ces secteurs la présence d'éolienne
de ferme photovoltaïques ou de
méthanisation à plus de 2 km comme sur
le modèle standard allemand
n'oublions pas que la préservation de
ces sites exceptionnels c'est la force
et l'attractivité de notre pays ne
revivons pas et cela va rappeler des
souvenirs à nos aînés la France
défigurée qui faisait l'objet d'une
émission de télévision dans les années
60 et 70 nous avons mis des décennies
pour mieux protéger nos paysages si tes
patrimoine remarquables pour enlever les
tôles ondulés enseigne ou
transformateurs disgracieux posé en
visibilité dans la prière de nombreux
pays admirent la constance de nos
efforts et copie nos règles oui ne
jetons pas
le bébé avec l'eau du bain et au
contraire concilions nos progrès
merci sur l'ensemble de ces amendements
je vais demander l'avis de la commission
monsieur Cazeneuve
merci
merci monsieur le président
mes chers collègues ça ne vous aura pas
échappé nous étudions ce soir un projet
de loi qui vise à accélérer le
développement
des énergies renouvelables et l'ensemble
de amendements qui ont été défendus sur
ces bancs vise à faire exactement le
contraire puisque c'est une sorte de
moratoire déguisé sous le coup des ABS
on a fait un petit exercice en regardant
ce que représentait 10 km autour de tous
les monuments historiques et ça a été
rappelé très justement il y a 46 000
monuments historiques mais je vais vous
le dire il reste un tout petit peu moins
de 100 km² en France qui échappe à cette
cartographie
donc
mais on voit bien là la tension mais au
moins je préfère qu'elle soit
parfaitement affichée alors les grands
gagnants je crois qu'il y a un petit
bout dans les Landes un petit bout en
Haute-Corse dans les Hautes-Alpes et
dans les Pyrénées-Atlantiques pour tout
le reste il y a donc cet avis conforme
des ABS sur le développement de si je
reviens
ah si donc si je reviens au droit
existant aujourd'hui il existe déjà des
choses qui protègent évidemment notre
patrimoine et je ne laisserai pas les
députés sur ces bancs
s'ériger en grande défenseur du
patrimoine parce que c'est une
préoccupation qui est partagée partout
ici et nous l'avons rappelé à de maintes
reprises et le gouvernement et la
majorité se sont positionnés sur ce
sujet à deux maintes reprises et nous
avons aucune leçon à recevoir sur le
sujet de la protection de notre
patrimoine donc aujourd'hui dans le
droit existant non c'est vous qui êtes
arrogant moi j'essaye de remettre les
choses en perspective donc aujourd'hui
nous avons des barrières il y a un avis
conforme des ABS à 500 mètres de ces
monuments historiques et c'est bien
normal pour les éoliennes
adopter votre amendement reviendrez
à bloquer littéralement bloqué tout
projet d'éolien sur notre territoire
parce que vous qui avez vous qui vous
qui savez mieux que moi ce que sont les
abeilles ils sont sans vents en France
et donc à 120 ils vont avoir du mal à
traiter même si vous pouvez dire que
c'est un avis ils vont avoir du mal à
traiter l'ensemble des dossiers donc
n'essayez pas de vous cacher derrière le
patrimoine pour défendre un énième
moratoire vous l'avez très bien fait
hier nous l'avons pas adopté donc ça
sera une demande de retrait évidemment
ça va à l'inverse de ce projet de loi
vous êtes en dehors de quel est
l'objectif de ce projet de loi encore
une fois c'est à dire
regagner en souveraineté énergétique
redonner la possibilité à nos
entreprises d'avoir de l'électricité à
des tarifs abordables
et lutter contre le dérèglement
climatique et certains que tous ici nous
partageons ces deux grands objectifs je
vous remercie
bien on va laisser les orateurs
s'exprimer dans le calme on a une heure
et une grosse heure et demie encore à
passer donc je suis persuadé qu'on va
pouvoir le faire est-ce que monsieur le
Président vous souhaitiez prendre la
parole non alors madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président alors cet
abonnement est un peu étonnant parce que
tout l'enjeu de ce projet de loi c'est
de permettre aux élus de terrain de
reprendre la main sur la planification
énergétique et de leur permettre de
définir les zones où ils vont accélérer
le développement des énergies
renouvelables et les zones où il ne ils
imposeront de ne pas le faire ce que
vous faites ici
c'est de donner à mais c'est intéressant
c'est de donner un fonctionnaire de
l'État en l'occurrence l'architecte des
bâtiments de France droit de vie ou
droit de mort sur tous les projets
portés par les élus de terrain c'est
très exactement comme ça que mon
remontée certains maires sur le
territoire leur perception de ce qui
avait été voté au Sénat et c'est
d'autant plus vrai que comme la très
bien dit le rapporteur lorsqu'on
applique un périmètre de 10 km et je
vais vous rassurer monsieur le député du
inconvénients 10 km 15 km au 20 km ça
fait très exactement la même carte parce
qu'en fait sur notre territoire français
comme là vous prenez la définition la
plus large d'éléments patrimonial c'est
tout le territoire français qui est
concerné vous prenez la Bretagne il n'y
a pas un espace en Bretagne à part des
zones extraordinairement limitées qui
permettent de développer les éoliennes
alors soyons clairs soyons clairs c'est
un refus de développer les énergies
renouvelables c'est un refus mais
assumez-le c'est pas un problème assumer
que vous ne voulez pas d'indépendance
énergétique de notre pays assumer que
vous ne voulez pas développer de
l'électricité ma carbone assumez que
vous préférez laisser les Français dans
le noir demain plutôt que de sortir des
énergies fossiles assumer que vous
préférez on laisse la ministre terminée
mais pardon c'est ça qu'il s'agit c'est
très sérieux est-ce que vous pensez une
minute qu'un maire n'est pas capable
lui-même
de dessiner l'endroit où il ne veut pas
d'énergie renouvelable
à quel moment le maire est mal placé
pour défendre son patrimoine pour des
fins de sa politique touristique pour
défendre son attractivité à quel moment
il va aller choisir l'endroit le pire
sur le territoire pour installer des
énergies renouvelables moi j'avoue je ne
comprends pas
et j'ajoute à ça j'ajoute à ça
qu'aujourd'hui
l'architecte des bâtiments de France
donne un avis simple qui permet
d'accompagner le maire dans un
instruction j'ajoute à ça qu'aujourd'hui
dans l'instruction d'un dossier la
dimension paysagère et patrimoniale est
prise en compte donc non seulement
aujourd'hui les enjeux patrimoniaux et
paysagers sont prises en compte et vos
intentions sont satisfaites mais en plus
vous privez les mères de la possibilité
d'agir donc c'est évidemment un avis
défavorable sur l'ensemble de ces
amendements
merci Madame la Ministre alors je vois
les demandes de prise de parole vous
aurez de toute façon tous la parole
puisque nous sommes en temps programmés
ça permet de revenir un petit peu dans
le calme et je vais donner la parole à
Pierre mein
dis donc merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre on vient de reprendre
la séance et vous êtes déjà en train de
vous énerver
vous vous dites qu'on est contre
l'indépendance énergétique mais vous
êtes j'espère que vous êtes pas sérieuse
c'est vous qui êtes en train de
simplifier des procédures en faveur
d'énergie intermittente qui vont nous
faire non seulement dépendre d'autres
puissances comme la chier de l'Allemagne
etc et qui vont en plus nous faire
dépendre de la météo sur laquelle nous
ne sommes pas des dieux et nous avons
aucune maîtrise donc vous ne maîtrisez
rien et vous êtes en train de nous
donner la leçon vous êtes en train de
nous donner la leçon est-ce que vous
êtes sérieuse je ne pense pas
reprenons sur l'architecte des bâtiments
de France
c'est facile de dire qu'on va simplifier
d'un coup sur les énergies renouvelables
et qu'on va supprimer la vie conforme
des de l'architecte des bâtiments de
France l'architecte des bâtiments de
France complexifie les procédures pour
de très nombreux projet structurant au
niveau local et il faudrait supprimer
cet avis conforme uniquement pour les
énergies renouvelables pourquoi aller
aussi vite de ce point de vue là
pourquoi et je rappelle ce qu'on fait un
peu de marteothérapie ce qu'on disait
hier c'est que on a un projet de loi
d'accélération procédurale et
aujourd'hui nous n'avons aucune vision
du mix énergétique que vous voulez pour
la France pour demain c'est un
supportable et c'est un mépris des
Français de la représentation nationale
donc la raison pour laquelle nous
voulons maintenir cet avis conforme de
l'architecte des bâtiments de France
c'est en effet en effet que vous nous
voulons limiter votre pouvoir de
développement anarchique de ces énergies
intermittentes oui nous n'avons pas
confiance en vous donc
arrêtez de nous faire la leçon comprenez
que nous n'avons pas ce confiance en
vous les Français nous regardent et eux
notamment dans les zones rurales n'ont
aucune confiance en vous
merci
Monsieur l'aîné
merci monsieur le Président
j'ai rappelé hier que mon groupe était
pour un scénario 100% renouvelable à
l'horizon 2050 mais je voudrais dire
quand même que notre souhaitons pas
couvrir la France d'éolienne pas plus
que nous souhaitons la couvrir de
panneaux photovoltaïques et j'espère
voilà
on ne souhaite pas la couvrir et
j'espère pouvoir compter d'ailleurs sur
les bancs d'autres collègues qui
voteront avec nous pour un encadrement
très strict de la grille voltaïsme on
verra ça dans la discussion suivantes
pour ça pour ça il va falloir justement
faire la planification il va falloir
contrer le marché ce qui est quand même
une dimension importante de ce projet de
loi et puis aussi avoir un grand débat
sur la sobriété alors ne souhaitons
encore moins couvrir la France de
nucléaire parce que il y a quand même
une espèce de chape qui pèse sur
l'ensemble de nos débats je vous ai
rappelé hier les trois scénarios de RTE
qui prévoit une relance de nucléaire
mais qui prévoit dans le même temps un
accroissement entre 40 et 50 gigawatts
d'éoliennes ce que ne disent pas les
partisans du nucléaire c'est qu'en fait
si on veut remplacer ces puissances
électriques qui sont prévues pour
développer par le nucléaire c'est qu'il
va falloir construire entre 15 20
réacteurs donc ici il y a quelques fans
de Stéphane Bern visiblement je voudrais
savoir si il est prévu une grande
émission sur le réacteur préféré des
Français en tout cas moi je pense que si
on leur posait la question
on aurait peut-être pas forcément plus
d'approbation que pour avoir une
éolienne dans le périmètre de
covisibilité comme il est de coutume de
dire j'en profite pour dire que nous ne
sommes pas contre les architectes des
bâtiments de France mais pour un avis
simple plutôt qu'un avis conforme voilà
je termine en disant que ces questions
énergétiques en fait il va falloir
peut-être un moment qui a un référendum
et un référendum qui arrive à la fin
d'un grand débat et un grand débat sur
le mix énergétique qui soit autre chose
que la parodie de concertation
confidentielle et numérique qui se passe
en même temps que nos travaux ici même
et qui doivent s'arrêter fin décembre
mais ou donc installer des éoliennes
c'est la question et elle est aprement
débattue en séance publique les députés
et le gouvernement tentent de trouver le
bon équilibre entre volonté nationale
d'avancer pour combler le retard
français et nécessiter de respecter les
spécificités des territoires et les
réserves des mers extrait de séance
madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur le fait que vous refusiez au
plus tôt que vous sembliez redouter un
avis conforme de l'architecte des
bâtiments de France n'est pas rassurant
et laisse à penser que le projet
d'accélération que vous portez peut
passer par le déploiement de champ
éolien à proximité de Monument inscrit
au classement ce qui ne nous semble ni
raisonnable ni acceptable si tel est le
cas si vous comptez vous affranchir du
respect de la proximité d'un monument
historique inscrit ou classé il faut le
dire très clairement afin que tout le
monde puisse voter en connaissance de
cause
merci Monsieur Dupont-Aignan
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre et le rapporteur ont avoué ils
ont dit les choses les Français qui nous
écoutent ce soir maintenant ont compris
le déploiement des 10000 15000 éoliennes
supplémentaires va vraiment saccager nos
plus beaux sites et un pays ce n'est pas
seulement des chiffres ce ne sont pas
seulement des faits c'est une histoire
c'est une émotion ce sont des paysages
du monde entier les gens viennent pour
voir la France et vous allez la détruire
mais comment pouvez-vous faire cela au
nom de l'environnement c'est incroyable
j'ajoute pour notre collègue qui a 56
sites nucléaires il y aura 10 000 15000
éoliennes de plus c'est pas tout à fait
la même chose je crois enfin je voudrais
dire que aujourd'hui aujourd'hui la
puissance délivrée par vos fameuses
éoliennes 8000 éoliennes ce matin
c'était 3% à 9h15 à midi ou à 13h selon
Arte Arte c'est pas une chaîne qui m'est
très favorable je crois c'était 1,95%
c'était la grande émission d'Arte ce
soir
1,95% pour une puissance installée de 14
%. alors on va massacrer les villages de
France on va massacrer la santé aussi de
tous ceux qui habitent autour parce
qu'il y a des monuments historiques mais
à ceux qui habitent autour avec des
études américaines allemandes qui
montrent que les infrasons vont au-delà
de 10 à 20 km mais ça vous n'en parlez
pas la santé des habitants ça nous
intéresse pas de ceux qui habitent là
c'est un massacre environnemental et au
nom de l'environnement vous détruisez
l'environnement des Français comment
pouvez-vous voter ça et moi je demande à
tous les Français de regarder qui va
voter ses projets qui va voter les
amendements parce qu'il faudra s'en
souvenir quand ils verront des mains de
250 mètres de haut à côté de chez eux il
faudra s'en souvenir c'est ça la vérité
merci monsieur le député Loïc herver
merci Monsieur le monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur madame la
ministre donc en fait dans cette série
d'amendements il y a des amendements qui
ont des positions plus mesurées moins
caricatural que ce qu'on pourrait croire
je pense en particulier à celui de mon
collègue Jérémy
patrietus qui part lui de zones
utile plutôt que de parler d'une d'une
distance uniquement et je voulais vous
dire que il y a un vrai sujet à mon sens
parce que le droit de vie ou de mort des
ABS aujourd'hui il existe sur beaucoup
de projets privés de nos concitoyens et
il y aurait vraiment un caractère
incompréhensible une forme de décalage
insupportable même démocratiquement à ce
que dans un secteur à proximité d'un
bâtiment classé on puisse mettre une
éolienne et on puisse pas poser un Velux
ou changer la couleur du crépi
je ne suis pas certain que de donner ce
pouvoir finalement à un administratif
par rapport aux élus ce soit forcément
une bonne chose puis tous ceux qui sont
maires ici ont certainement eu à faire
aux ABS et alors les ABS c'est quand
même des gens qui sont parfois curieux
moi je vois un secteur protégé que je
connais très bien côté de chez moi la BF
il a autorisé une maison à toi plat dans
un secteur qui est 16e 17e siècle on
peut se demander ce qui lui a pris mais
elle n'empêche que la maison elle est là
et quand on va sur le château on voit
cette maison là donc c'est assez
incroyable alors après il y a la BF qui
change alors un coup c'est des fenêtres
en rouge et puis après c'est des
fenêtres en bleu ah oui il faut changer
ah bah oui c'est comme ça parce que ça a
changé d'abf donc la BF donne le ton moi
je suis désolé mais je trouve que c'est
pas une bonne chose et je vous le dis
tout de suite le jour où il y aura un
ABS qui est favorable aux éoliennes il
autorisera les éoliennes à côté de
monuments ne vous inquiétez pas donc
c'est pas une bonne chose que de leur
donner le pouvoir voilà pour cette
séance le débat continue rendez-vous sur
LCP.fr et sur la chaîne Youtube de LCP
pour revoir d'autres moments
parlementaires très bonne suite de
programmation